et après le père on va parler maintenant
du fils encore plus précoce à 22 ans
Jean Sarkozy est déjà conseiller général
des hautes scènes on a même évoqué ces
derniers jours un poste important à
l'UMP mais cela a été démenti le fils
cadet du chef de l'État est en tout cas
lui aussi un homme pressé mais il a
choisi de s'implanter d'abord dans son
département quitte à en déranger
certains Charles Sanviti et François
Renaud c'est gentil d'être venu et que
la fête commence ce soir au département
s jour de liè la distribution est au
complet messieur devjan balcani sans
oublier junior ou Sarkozy fil un rival
en herbe que Patrick dejan salue
ironiquement je me réjouis que les
énergies neuves montent et s'expriment
dans les hautes scènes et que notre
département soit le symbole du
renouvellement et c'est vrai à 22 ans
Junior est déjà conseiller général
président du groupe UMP majoritaire dans
les hautes scènes de qui porter ses
influents précepteurs je l'ai vu naître
genre et donc évidemment quand il est
arrivé dans le département où je siège
depuis 20 ans bon ben quand il avait
peut-être des conseils à demander il est
venu plus naturellement vers moi mais
pas plus que ça alors si vous avez aimé
le père vous adorerez le fils pressé
boulimique et un brun tonton flingueur
au municipal en mars dernier il lâche
avec l'aval de l'Élysée David Martinon
le tête de liste finalement jettera
l'éponge faut dire la vérité aux gens il
faut dire on va dans le mur qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on change de cap on reste
dans le coin du ring
isolé donc pas d'état d'â et le
spectacle continue encouragé par la
dévotion des
fans il est tout à fait remarquable il
ira loin sûrement Bonaparte désigné
prier consul à 30 ans lui en a 22 pour
ses détracteurs n'a pas eu à conquérir
juste à recevoir lui s'en défend surtout
pas carriériste juste politiquement
studieux moi personnellement si vous
m'interrogez je me suis pas engagé pour
réfléchir à quel chapeau à plume et je
porterai je me suis engagé pour être
utile à la place qui est la mienne alors
cache-cache des ambitions sous l'œil de
Charles pasquy le patriarche il y a 25
ans déjà ne lui échappait
au profit d'un certain Nicolas
Sarkozy